oh wait that's my other intro I mean
how's it going breath - very bad
and welcome to what Sundays when peridot
pie I'm sorry brothers I am sometimes
this is really hard I do everything by
myself with this channel and it's just
hard to get things done in time so I'm
sorry I'm fully aware it's Sunday but I
know you bros are ok with it oh and also
I know I need a haircut so 1 million
comments can do it you can go ahead to
make your comment now go ahead I'm
waiting thank ya so yeah today we're
gonna open some mail I got way too much
that I haven't opened in a while so
that's doing you're gonna watch it we're
gonna join everything I don't know I
just feel like changing it out today I
got this and it's a scribble odds I have
to finish that series I am aware of it
but yeah um scribble not boobs what you
gonna do about it
breast implants are not healthy Thanks I
got this blank oh it's upside down how
did you know you were actually right so
thank you bro I I love it I'm gonna put
it in the background this package says
hat on it and I need a hat so pirate
bank I don't know you press don't have
to see my hat anymore
spank me I've been a bad girl why would
we write fat if they send me a pair of
underwear what
it's sad a hat - I like the other fault
write in the comments if you think I
look beautiful
whoa whoa whoa whoa love eating it bank
it's a careful around why don't break it
well it's awesome I love I love stuff
like this that comes from do you know
where this is from
do yo it's from Johnny good it's banged
it's awesome I love it thank you all
right I got some awesome I should take
this off should night we got some
awesome t-shirts from a bro and they say
I'm too short and I'm too awesome and
they are awesome
those thank you me and myself I'm patty
all right so a couple of Bros from
Germany sent to me this belt or whatever
and and with a bunch of alcohol
don't drink bras you're supposed to take
these and you put them in here or
whatever but actually a bit of pledget I
would never get drunk in a video I felt
like there's a lot of places to get
drunk but I feel like YouTube is not one
of them the Internet is well but hey
it's so tiny
it's not time look at this I opened oh
nothing happened
nothing happened Oh oopsie it's open
oopsie I better drink it
oh well that's good see nothing happen
by Norma so this bro from Australia
probably paid a ton of money if then his
will he says hope you enjoy all the
stuff in here I work at eBay games of
his easy to get together and he sent me
Kingdom Hearts its favorite game that he
wants me to play along with the
PlayStation Slim's so I can record it
that is crazy
thank you let me know Rose if you wanted
to see me play this game I already seen
a ton of you suggested and I never
actually today myself thank you will
that's insane thank you so much okay
Russ this looks kind of scary it says
German Laden Adnan and in him it's more
alcohol like it yes goodbye the man with
a million fate says that's awesome
what's a puny collage pie yeah yeah oh
and the German browser also sent me this
awesome painting it says Peter pie we
love you that is the most sweet thing
I have ever seen no this seriously
I guess that's all the time at for today
there's so many more packages that I
have not opened but I don't want to take
the time and say thank you both for just
sending me all these stuff it feels
amazing to get it receive so many
awesome gifts for me I don't know I
don't know what it is I do I really
don't get it but I feel like I live the
dream and it's all thanks to you bro so
thank you so much for watching my videos
it really means the world to me thank
you again I don't know if I probably
said things but we reached by five
million brows which is [ __ ] Chris
stupid
something like I was amazed by one man I
was amazed by a [ __ ] thousand when I
got that so 5 million is dislike that's
how I described 5 million I I don't get
it but I appreciate all Negroes dropping
in it like I said it means the world to
me like it makes me so happy that you
both watched my videos just that but
receiving awesome stuff and it makes me
even happier so for that you guessed it
just can't double process that you
weren't expecting that were you for your
work
well normal left hand frozen but you
weren't expecting that
just kidding it's a regular growl fifty
thousand caramel activate just kidding I
brofist read my blood you just brofist
tip it advice but how does that make you
feel
you